Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott are
reportedly taking a break
if my true fans there want to know
person according to multiple outlets the
pair is taking some time to themselves
after more than two years of dating TMZ
reports that they tried to make things
work but have chosen to take a break
from their relationship baby okay Travis
and Kylie's last public appearance
together was in late August at the
rapper's premiere for his Netflix
documentary look mom I can fly their
one-year-old daughter stormy attended
the premiere with them they posed for
photos together on the red carpet
affectionately smiling and even
smooching their baby girl on the cheek
[Music]
before news of the break the adorable
family was seen livin it up over the
summer which included a lavish trip to
Europe to celebrate Kylie's 22nd
birthday on a mega yacht and just last
month the 22 year old beauty mogul posed
nude for Playboy with her bow leading
the creative direction in one of the
sexy snaps Kylie embraces a shirtless
Travis their editorial spread was part
of Playboy's 20-19 pleasure issue 11 the
duo first sparked romance rumors in
April 2017 and constantly kept fans
guessing if they were possibly engaged
or even married often calling each other
husband and wife on social media
earlier this year rumors started
swirling that Travis had allegedly
cheated on Kylie which she vehement ly
denied in a statement and that's not
gonna twist it
[Music]